the art of thoughtful disagreement is
the basis of a very
uh Innovative and also harmonious
Society if you want to have an
Innovative harmonious Society you have
to have the art of thoughtful
disagreement and the mediator is a very
uh important role so that you played
um because like I I wrote in my other
book principles one of the handy things
is if you're having a disagreement one
of you might be wrong and how do you
know and how do you get past that and so
the uh classic thing is to find to agree
on somebody who you mutually agree will
uh be a fair judge and a fair mediator
and if you mutually agree on that person
then you bring them then they can get
you they can help you along and the
exercise of going above it and saying
okay here's this disagreement and how do
we deal with disagreement on
each other related to the disagreement
that is a good perspective to have yeah
and so I think that as we look at all
those things I think that it's so clear
that approaches like that are and
perspectives like that are very very
helpful